the chords of hours
[Music]
better
on time
is exactly canary
even gas
nothing
ah
save
yes
[Music] they
know everything
[Music]
curators learned
more face
[Music]
guayas
mary
amical
post more
another dead
but
even marica market
ah
but penn
with  cow
in
[Music]
also this person
and
loads
jessica biel
i more
that is per person
assistant keith walls
also
nothing
eye there is nothing in the jr
[Music]
things
that person
rafa benítez
i
to notify pass
michael wilding
min
down
today
and  well
listen baby
nothing has changed
about the inns
i
yes
here
h
ah
the desert
[Music]
and
strawberries
i
and what's left
is it's a sale and only
now
wright
ah
csif
[Music]
why
uy it's
worth
more
ah
since there is
to mark
ah
It's not like that
and
and maybe
hello
at first glance
I'm not exaggerating
and I
spend
for this payment
what is
albert white
here
[Music]
nothing
na
and agrarian
when it's already
here here
agüer
hello
has one is  White dinner
very expensive
and
it's not
in o grove
ok
best buy and yet let's
see
the bid is perverse pringles
nothing is serious
texas is expensive
that's in the 9
what
but what is that
why does he
talk about suites or sea
but no
nadia petrova
ah
That's how it's
safe it
can be valuable no
neymar quality leader
dt a
here sometimes I hit
think
and in the chapel
shots
were meirás watch and design
and
ok
also eat
way
with 6 in one
jose juan
i
ah
station put it's cool
before they start
better than  the human contents
michael
ah
efe
take
word
ah
am
normally
i
accident
in law
director of network lake change the world
before golden gloves
data
howard
take
my cut
what i like
that is in the state
i always sleep
well
not
yesterday
like this
seixas
[  Música]
s
in station ue that is to say os
i
yesterday
christ no one
well
the concession one
enrique to
him exposes
etc
sherman
for what of
course
for
but
ah
to karen
my life
and
i well
in these regattas
ah
[Applause]
to
ah
no no
peter
buck why
and yesterday they
even put that verse on sexual genre for us we are
going to be
yes
out
the police
brian at
for bayern franz marc in the century
when exposing put in space
is this
nothing more than water
the cow
i
why
what is there
and we see after hitting
tex mex you want to know we
respond
ah sometimes
in shock
to desiccate neuronal anr
ah
e
maybe
the meat
javier are
tablemac have been
[Music]
j
here
[Applause]
but
she
[Music]
although
they are scarce
well
and
or not
ok
[Music]
I have someone left
mike
ok
to camps
and you say you
want t
that's how scaroni would stay
ah
mari carmen linares off
no
and
on the 20th of scanner week attack
i
that they may acquire
in build
not
clear
my book which one
this  year
at least
yes
and ours
the wing wife
that there are bars
and the sun is
good loaded
m
and why
in dollars
maybe
ah
yes
flowers are beneficial
you
ah
and
yes I know
when
in the cmd
of energy
I have no hair
they are born to do nothing
and to
the mark of their hand
what's my own way
ah
strawberries
and
[Music]
in brown
and
d
first
[Music]
and
Tunisian
I want to see action
if I am protected from asthma
ah
[Music]
now she
today
water
uu
that is
and continue
now
a dinner do
yes
suites antlers
efe
[Music]
typical traditional prevention
i
your house
and
our dresses flour
make are the shocks of age
to die
[Applause]
so
novartis right
n
want to see
and
then
d
good
but  requires in
front
perhaps
Aztec selection
here
although this list
and
i
you for know
give me
[Music]
and
feature pure
wang stay
harmon
in the place
what else
not
the sixth
is to
touch anyone
perhaps
the clown
the atheist
ah
and drain
with the mind
why
ah
sweetheart
this general general
here is no one
not from
the wave
i
and
ah
accident that is starting to come back
if the teachers don't go
now
peter freeman on the subject
cold sometimes  del monte mayor
here
or
several goals
from the canary islands
[Music]
no
but
there is a
good one
to know
[Music]
when he dies
m
is there
macro makers
[Music]
why
and
for that
[Music]
from wear
wow
texas blessed
ah